(upbeat music)
- [Men Whispering] Dead Kevin
(vacuum)
- Guys it's looking great.
- Wanna help me move the couch?
- What?
So I can vacuum?
- Ready?
- Yeah, ready?
- One, Two, Three
(all grunting)
- Oh, oh yeah!
- Do you mind if I?
- I think I remember when I
first moved in.
- I dropped it on the ground.
- A few weeks ago
- I had a dollar
- No, here's the thing,
I am usually, honestly,
the one who has the most
dollars, so statistically,
but I don't need it,
but it is probably
- Yeah, I mean I was always
kind of more of a cash guy.
- What does that mean?
- You do use credit,
we use, we're like cash
- [Guy Green Shirt] I have a
shoe box in my room that I just
- You know I feel like
you guys need it the most,
I don't need it the
most, necessarily
- [Guy Green Shirt]
I don't need it.
- [Guy Purple Shirt]
Yeah okay I need it.
I need it.
- [Guy Green Shirt] Yeah but
I don't, I think we've agreed
that it's not yours.
- [Guy Red Shirt] I
agree that you need it,
because of how your life is
going, but I earn it because
of hard work and
education. And I, so.
- Need it, I'm just
gonna say I need it.
- It's my dollar.
- I don't
- You can't just say
that. You can't just say
- Know that honestly, I
don't mean to attack but this
is typical of you.
- But you do attack.
You do attack, constantly.
- I don't want this to
compromise, to come come between
- Do you remember last week?
- No, no because I
don't remember, Jack,
I don't remember.
- But you didn't let me say
- What I remember is that
I'm usually, statistically
- No, but remember I was like,
we should get some strippers
- Oh! The strippers thing
- And I threw up
all the money I had
- You threw up dollars
and no strippers came.
- Ey! Hey!
Let's just leave the dollar.
It's not worth it.
- Yeah I mean he's right man.
It's like it's just a dollar.
- Just leave for the next
people who live here?
- It's like a good deed.
- Yeah
- Do our good deed
and leave my dollar.
- Leave a dollar.
Leave the dollar.
- [Guy Red Shirt]
Yeah, screw it.
- [Purple Shirt Guy]
It's just a dollar.
- [Green Shirt Guy]
Bury the secret.
- It's a dollar.
- What are we, crazy?
- If I had a dollar for
every time we fought over
a dollar, I'd have a dollar!
- We're best friends
- We'll go our separate
ways, and then we'll all
be fine about it.
- Hey!
- Hey you get back here, I
knew he was going to do this.
- It was mine anyways!
- Alright, you can
have the dollar.
- It's Jack's dollar.
It's your dollar.
- Oh P.U, the economy
stink hurts, stinks.
Look at way down at the Dow
Jones and how inflation is
affecting you.
- Oh we'd just like
you to subscribe.
- What's weird things
you do with money?
- Affecting you.